so continuing our series on omega-level
mutant which focuses explicitly on the
powers of marvel's most powerful mutants
we pick up now with Nate gray also known
as x-men now for those of you who are
unfamiliar with the terminology of
omega-level this phrasing is designed to
reference individuals who can warp
reality are inherently immortal meaning
they can't be killed by any normal means
or have a level of telepathy and
telekinesis that have reached the point
where they can't be surpassed having
said that if you haven't seen my video
on the origins of cable which you'll
find in the description we had talked
about how his mutant powers of telepathy
and telekinesis were greatly reduced due
to being exposed to the techno-organic
virus by apocalypse as a result instead
of allowing his powers to expand
naturally at a young age he was taught
and has consistently used as powers to
keep the virus from eating him alive
something that has kept cable away from
the opportunity to reach his full
potential and achieve Omega level status
however for Nate gray this was never an
issue originally hailing for the age of
apocalypse timeline an alternate reality
resulting from the mutant David Haller
traveling into the past and killing
Charles Xavier because the death of
Professor Xavier prevented the formation
of the x-men as we know them the villain
apocalypse has seized the opportunity to
take control of North America while some
of these changes were small and that
magneto had led the johnny-come-lately
x-men instead of Xavier other changes
were huge and that the Avengers the
Fantastic Four and spider-man were
either killed off or never formed as a
team in addition to these varying
differences between the age of
apocalypse and the main Marvel Universe
the mutant geneticist mr. sinister
believed that the offspring of Jean Grey
and Scott Summers would produce a child
of incredible power capable of
destroying apocalypse and ending his
reign however unlike the main model
continuity because the x-men never
formed under Xavier the opportunity
never occurred for Jean and Scott to
engage in a coupling but because both
mutants had served time and the pins
under the experimentation of beast who
was a direct servant of sinister
sinister was able to use their DNA as it
had been acquired by Hank McCoy allowing
him to clone a child it's for this
reason that much like strife who exists
as cables clone make great is
essentially what cable would have been
had he not been infected by the
techno-organic virus however unlike
strife Nate grey was destined for
premature death and that when sinister
cloned him he had removed the natural
barriers that kept Nate's powers in
check meaning that once he reached
maturity the
Norma's amount of energy he possessed
would quite literally burn his body out
having said that and his original
appearances Nate Gray's power was not
highly defined instead the Age of
Apocalypse consistently alluded to the
idea that Nate gray had massive amounts
of energy which were commonly depicted
in primitive forms of telepathy and
telekinesis as a result this revelation
combined with the depiction of his
character as coming of age in a world
ruled by apocalypse who made him
extremely popular among the Marvel
reader based meaning that when Age of
Apocalypse ended and the timeline was
reset to normal
Nate Gray was folded into the main
Marvel Universe with his own self-titled
line of comics now focusing on his
powers where Nate gray quite literally
fell out of the sky and landed in the
main mobile continuity his initial
arrival did not draw the attention of
anyone and therein was Marvel's first
indication that may gray possess
incredible abilities an x-man issued
number 10 following his arrival to the
main Marvel Universe the mutant telepath
and telekinetic time-traveling on his
watch Smith had informed Charles Xavier
that a mutant with the same genetic
signature as cable had arrived in their
time investigating the scene for himself
prior to meeting with Xavier black Smith
discover that Nate gray had stumbled
into dark beast the version of Hank
McCoy who had also survived the Age of
Apocalypse where blacksmith originally
thought that Nate might have been strife
another omega-level mutant and the clone
of cable black Smith also came to the
realization that the powers of Nate gray
exceeded those of cable and even
Professor Xavier now the importance of
this was that as a world's most powerful
telepath while Xavier did since Nate
grey for a few seconds this only came
when they arrived on earth after which
he immediately hid himself from Xavier
and cerebro something that was believed
to be impossible this particular bit was
expanded on in the two-part story
covered between x-man issue number 12
and Excalibur issue number 95 and then
after being taken to more McTaggart for
examination regarding his abilities she
discovered that the telepathic and
telekinetic power Nate possessed was on
par with Jean Grey as the Phoenix force
as a result of this admits telepathy
Nate gray can read the minds of others
to learn and understand all languages
perfectly he could read thoughts and
emotions left on objects that have
previously been touched he can detect
rifts in the fabric of space and time
and he can leave his physical body
allowing him to journey to the astral
plane where he can see the future with
relative accuracy in addition to this as
a solo series continued on his powers
were
found by their constant use meaning that
by issue number 32 titled who or what is
jackknife Nate gray was shown to be
capable in increasing the abilities of
other mutants or entities to higher
levels furthermore an x-man issued
number 40 titled wint hundred strikes
during a battle the tundra who is an
extra dimensional being capable of
controlling the earth itself may gray
overpower tundra by manipulating and
isolating the gravitational pull around
the villain which resulted in tundra
being pulled apart of the seams and
imploding under the extreme pressure on
top of this an x-man issue 63 and 67
Nate's telekinesis was powerful enough
that he could move the chemicals around
in a woman's brain curing her of cancer
he collapsed a city 2,600 miles away
while having a nightmare
he can manipulate the particles of sand
and water allowing him to make Holograms
of himself that could interact with the
world around him he could control the
molecules of light to make himself
invisible he could projecting cus of
blasts capable of impacting matter on
the atomic level he could manipulate the
molecules of solid matter or himself
allowing him to face through physical
objects he could absorb the
electromagnetic spectrum of the earth
and use it to enhance his concussive
attacks he could heal himself from
virtually any attack and he could use as
telekinesis to break the barriers of
space and time allowing him to move to
any dimension or point in time now
having said all that because the term
Omega level mutant wasn't officially
introduced until Grant Morrison's run on
new x-men at the conclusion of the x-man
series because an evil version of Jean
Grey from the earth 9 575 reality had
been around since the beginning of the
series serving to influence and
manipulate Nate the entire time an issue
number 70 at the conclusion of the
four-part shockwave storyline that of
all the versions in the multiverse
including cable and strife meet gray was
the most powerful version of himself
whether smen was that where the term
Omega level didn't exist at the time
this phrasing was meant to indicate
Omega level status however because Nate
had been so powerful and still had a fan
base but also found interest in
prospective fans who would only read
about his character while the death of
Nate came in 2001 with x-man issue
number 75 after he converted himself to
pure energy following the events of
civil war dark rain and seas leading
into the heroic age in 2010 with dark
x-men issue number 2 Nate grey made his
return to Marvel Comics where he was
officially given Omega level
classification by Hank McCoy and worked
explain the power he possessed prior to
his death and the power he would
eventually develop if allowed to
continue living without being said we're
gonna bring this video to an end and if
you guys are interested in seeing a full
on character discussion of Nate gray let
me know in the comments section below
and I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]